VACHARA: Hi, my name is Vachara from Computerology.
I develop applications using Google Maps API.
[TRANSLATED FROM THAI] We developed many applications that connect to various platforms.
Google Maps API is one of our favorites.
I would like to show you an application where we use the Google Maps API
Service Point System for Siam Commercial Bank.
Siam Commercial Bank is one of the biggest banks in Thailand.
There are approximately 7,000 ATM service points all over in Thailand.
We developed this application to display information about branches, ATMs, and money exchange service points.
Users can search by specifying by province district, operation time, or zip code.
Moreover, for the organization's look and feel, we used Styled Maps to change the color of the map.
One of our interesting applications is "Check Elevation".
Last year, Thailand had trouble with a flooding crisis in all regions of central Thailand, including Bangkok.
To help people in flood areas, we developed a system based on Google Maps and the Elevation API.
Users of the application can check the elevation of an area.
For example, flooding in Sutthisan.
When we check the Sutthisan area, Sutthisan is 3.86m high.
But if your home is located on Intamara Street, that has an elevation of 3.33m.
When compared to the area, which is almost the same height,
this means you have a chance to get affected by flood.
You can share information to Twitter or Facebook if you are in danger.
[ENGLISH] What I like about working with Google Maps API is
being able to bring the world's information into my application.